los combates siguen causando estragos en
la capital sudanesa pero en jetda hay
indicios de un avance diplomático
Estados Unidos y Arabia Saudita han
anunciado un acuerdo entre las dos
facciones enfrentadas en Sudán es un
acuerdo de César fuego de siete días y
se renovará automáticamente hasta que
alcancemos un alto al fuego permanente
está previsto que el alto al fuego
comience el lunes por la noche hasta
entonces el ejército sudanés y las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido han acordado
abstenerse de Buscar ventajas militares
el acuerdo fue negociado por Washington
y read al margen de la Cumbre de la liga
árabe no es el primer alto el fuego que
se anuncia y las treguas anteriores han
sido violadas pero la declaración afirma
que este acuerdo es el primero de este
tipo A diferencia de anteriores se hacía
el fuego el acuerdo alcanzado en jedi
fue firmado por las partes y contará con
el apoyo de un mecanismo de supervisión
del alto el fuego apoyado por Estados
Unidos Arabia Saudita y la comunidad
internacional tras cinco semanas de
conflicto los enfrentamientos
entre el ejército y el grupo paramilitar
fuerzas de acción rápida han llevado al
país a una situación insostenible los
combates han causado centenares de
muertos y más de un millón de
desplazados